because I was like really I'm really
late you weren't giving me anything I
want you to keep playing oh really it's
not that you're good you can the other
end of them to the yeah yeah
we were about to be funny but yeah I
mean we got those like there yeah that
is maybe that's not where he was born
water than where he was frog god those
feet are staring Tyler like I saw hello
everybody my name is Marlon what two
spore with wait I got Tyler he's just
got done creating a new adventure we
didn't even get any input on it he's
gonna name it
right what is the name there Tyler what
are you gonna work on that
porn porn Parran Parran Perrin par am
run our poor on our barn
pardon our poor on our pond or er nah
rien Benari aureus burn poor in arborlon
enter the world powerful riffing a
horrific creature you you absolute
nightmare on legs with arms for some
reason and a butt that sticks out about
a fee oh they smile they smiling at me
oh you get to learn all your new skills
cuz you're a baboon it's legs and arms
or three inches apart
dance dance baby yeah tap their nepa
yeah me go I'm on a town on a brown when
he walks into the club okay you can
actually go back to your home base
because now you can recruit your friends
I'm ready for puberty mama one more
Tyler
like on the mini-map you can see like
your the campsites you already extincted
the question marks are what you need to
go towards yeah you can find new that
we're not you know no I said go towards
the question marks that's nothing that's
literally nothing no no no no no go to
the closest question yeah yeah yeah how
do you like I don't get it there's the
right choice and then that's at the very
wrong is choice and you pick the very
wrongest it's not even on the list of
online click on them they're very strong
don't attack them go somewhere and be no
dojo kill their babies do not oh they
look like they're singsong and they're
tiny
remember to strike that's three dead
instantly you're so good I'll take a
bite oh you're so cute one one move your
camera to see what you're doing now you
go get that guy you get camp on the dead
corpse of his parent come run back your
fake laugh again you did it your brain
is so big that big now you can build up
your stay through your friend
before now you can hang out with of -
yeah true I mean hey the building blocks
of friendship are screwing oh yeah and
then everlasting love
actually I usually go or because you
just want to get one hey you guys walk
into a bar one of them dies welcome back
to SportsZone
okay or we can kill the war whatever the
only Ganga way yes please run home run
home run home home home home that's not
home is left
are you dead how'd they kill me they
were faster than you you've such a long
but you know most people like big butts
you got a long wait I want a fan art to
draw this like a fan artists to draw
each ear cheeks stretches out beyond
your body the same length of your body
cheek moving independently someone
please make that a real thing for the
internet to efficiently key from The
Lion King
really that's exactly what I was
thinking Rafiki with really long cheeks
you know wearing a top half and then
like oh by the way I think that's your
mom that's why you're not me yeah you
should maybe your mom wasn't that fun
alright thank you for watching
darling
I always will see in the next one
loves weed twice as much as he ever
loved you shut up you know our mother on
the complicated man
alright fine that one